aujourd'hui on va se parler d'une montre
connectés ça fait quelques bons mois
forçant 2019 man afin que vous êtes
parler d'une montre de faux si c'était
la cinquième génération c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec fossiles pour vous
présenter leur nouvelle montre la
faucille de sixième génération wave mort
ou est face à james ex fossiles elle est
à mon poignet depuis quelques jours je
vous donnais mon retour pour savoir
c'est le fossile de sixième génération
est intéressante ou pas alors petit
spoiler elle est intéressante voilà mais
la suite vous le verrez après donc on
continue à regarder et on va jusqu'au
bout bah oui c'est mieux comme ça allez
on y va
[Musique]
il existe plusieurs modèles sur le site
de fossiles ça c'est le bracelet en
silicone cdu 44 mm au niveau de mon
cadre ans un petit bracelet en 22 mm qui
vraiment sympa et en plus il est
totalement interchangeables à le
regarder il ya s'installer très
facilement c'est un bracelet classique
un très très très simple vous pouvez
venir régler tout à y déployer moi j'ai
plutôt des petits poignets et pour
autant ça va sans aucun problème c'est
une banque qui est élégante qui est
vraiment sympa vous avez des captures
qui sont vraiment intéressants pour la
santé également pour le sport et si vous
souhaitez vous pouvez venir à l'échangé
très facilement vous poussez salle à
vous retirer bracelet vous en mettez un
hôte ya une grande grande grande
collection sur le site de fossiles allez
jeter un coup d'oeil donc si vous voulez
un bracelet en cuir vous pouvez avoir un
bracelet en cuir si vous voulez plus du
métal vous pouvez la voir et si vous
voulez comme ici eh bien voyez une
montre avec un bracelet silicone scheer
est également très bien pour aller faire
du sport et jolie quand même berné plat
ça viendra mais qu'avait fossiles dessus
vous avez trois boutons boutons
principal avec une petite molette
paulien naviguer très facilement donc
passé le bouton rotatif il est très très
cool les deux boutons au dessus et en
dessous sont complètement
personnalisable donc ça c'est vraiment
vraiment bien alors moi le bouton du
haut je les assigner up la regarder ça
va arriver tout de suite à mon petit
spotify donc je peux venir piloter même
musique très facilement avec mon bouton
ici donc ça ça me plaît bien et le
bouton du bas je les assigner
directement alors à mon capteurs pour
venir mesurer ma fréquence cardiaque
pour autant vous ferez ce que vous
voulez pour venir les paramétrer c'est
très très très très simple regardez vous
voulez dans vos paramètres vous allez
ensuite dans personnalisation dans
personnalisation vous allez dans bouton
physique et ensuite vous choisissez vous
avez plein d'applications peuvent lire a
assigné alors si vous êtes plus sportive
vous avez des applications pour le sport
ici n nite run club qui est installé par
défaut votre planning plus productivité
le pstore si vous voulez votre
application de téléphone si ça vous
intéresse également youtube musique
enfin à venir installer en plus c'est
une musique mais on peut la voir très
facilement le lavage de mains le
minuteur la torche bref il ya plein
plein d'applis alors comme on est ici
effectivement sur du webos je sais pas
si vous connaissez bien webos ou est roi
c'est l'expérience google pour la montre
connectés et wes c'est très très
couleurs petit aparté au delà de ce
qu'on peut faire avec la montre avec
webos vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à vous et votre google maps et
votre playlist or avec tout votre
catalogue d'applications une sélection
d'applis préférait pas mal c'est
vraiment vraiment bien optimisé surtout
pour pour le sport c'est une montre un
c'est normal qu'on va avoir la larme
amazon alexa qui arrive bientôt qui pour
l'instant n'est pas encore dispo mais ça
ne saurait tarder le bien-être brienza
c'est ma liste de courses l'application
de méditation calme votre suivi de
rythme cardiaque le chronomètre les
contacts le fit le sport bref qu'un a
des tonnes c'est ça qui est vraiment
intéressant avec l'expérience ou air eau
s by google si vous aimez google si vous
avez un ou plusieurs comptes google
pourquoi pas même prévenir et cite les
synchroniser données de santé sport pour
la productivité pour tous et en plus
vous avez bien évidemment vos
notifications ce soit instagram facebook
linkedin tout ce que vous voulez
messenger j'en passe et des meilleurs
vous les avez oublié de vous préciser si
c'est un boîtier en acier inoxydable
alors bien qu'on voit ici cet aspect
avec une petite manip c'est juste de la
déco vous allez voir venir tourner ici
avec votre petit petites roues petite
molette vous arrivez dans vos
notifications où vous arrivez up
directement dans votre petit centre de
contrôle sur le dessus et puis après
c'est dur ouais ça c'est très très
simple là vous allez retrouver votre
google pour venir lui poser des
questions et compagnie ok ça marche vous
avez vos petites applications préférées
sur le côté l'activité la pluie la météo
bref le cardio ça c'est vachement bien
sûr le dessus le centre de contrôle et
en bas ce sont les différentes
notifications vous allez pouvoir
retrouver ici la plate forme et si au
tourne sur un qualcomm snapdragon 4100
plus une seule à 30% performance en plus
par rapport à la cinquième génération ça
vous paraîtra d'ouvrir plus rapidement
vos différentes applications on aura
plus de réactivité en plus ça va venir
apporter en gain d'autonomie à
l'autonomie c'est vraiment extrêmement
fort et que fossiles mais vraiment en
avant et dans vos paramètres vous avez
gros gros point fort qui est fait sur la
batterie intelligent qu'une gestion de
la batterie qui est complètement
intelligent qu ici moi j'aimais en mode
quotidien c'est à dire que les préjugés
de la recharger tous les jours la
plupart des fonctionnalités sont activés
conçu pour la recharge nocturne vous
l'utilisez la journée vous le charger le
soir c'est le mode sur lequel je suis
prêt pouvait venir personnalisé ça c'est
intéressant et vous choisissez écran
toujours active et oui non touchés pour
allumer oui/non incliné pour allumer
l'écran planification du bluetooth
activé ou désactivé bref vous le faites
vraiment les cartes comme ça vous
n'activer que ce dont vous avez besoin
voyez par exemple devenir active est ok
google qui n'étaient pas activées ça va
venir consommer davantage donc ça
dépendra vraiment une fois de plus si
vous voulez consommer davantage ou pas
vous venez tout tout tout paramétrer ici
donc là je suis dans nos réglages voyez
up ne sauvegarde pas et je vais avoir un
autre mode le mode qui est étendu ou là
par contre je vais emmener mon autonomie
un peu plus loin activer les fonctions
essentielles lorsque vous en avez besoin
destiné à être rechargée à intervalles
réguliers de quelques jours donc on va
la pousser un petit peu plus loin j'aime
les infos ici je vois ce qu'il en est
c'est plutôt intéressant et ans si je
peux avoir juste afficher l'heure
seulement quand j'ai plus de batterie je
passe en mode afficher l'heure seulement
ça permet de savoir quelle heure il joue
son rôle de montres uniquement son rôle
de notre ici plus connectés jeu basculer
en mode étendu c'est à dire le mode qui
va venir consommer un petit peu moins de
façon automatique lorsque je suis à 10%
en plus ici on est une charge qui
amélioré alors ya ça qui vous est livré
avec ses sons câble de charge on n'a pas
de blog de charge donc il faudra
utiliser un petit blog des charges à
venir trouver en plus vous le branchez
sur un ordi un pour recharger assez
rapidement en une demi heure vous l'avez
rechargée à 80% donc autant vous dire
que ça va quand même relativement vite
je ne vous recommande pas devenir le
brancher le soir et de débrancher le
lendemain matin ce que je vous conseille
de faire soit vous le branchez un petit
peu le soir pendant une demi heure 40
minutes 45 minutes maximum et ensuite
vous le débrancher vous êtes parti pour
une journée soit vous le branchez pas le
soir vous le branchez le matin quand
vous vous réveillez et vous êtes parti
parce qu'en plus c'est un truc qui est
vraiment intéressant ici au niveau des
données de santé c'est le suivi du
sommeil et pour avoir le suivi du sommet
il faut avoir ça montre au poignet et si
on a la montre au poignet on peut pas la
changer l'année moi je ne suis pas du
tout adepte du suivi du sommeil j'ai du
mal à dormir avec une monde c'est la
raison pour laquelle je ne l'utilisent
pas mais si vous souhaitez monitorer
votre sommeil savoir un peu ce qui se
passe au niveau de votre sommeil les
différentes phases si vous dormez bien
pas bien et compagnie et bien vous
pouvez le faire directement dans votre
montre ça s'est vraiment bien et on voit
que de plus en plus de constructeurs
qu'ils vont là dessus sur la donnée de
santé au niveau de l'amont ce qui fait
que vous venez de recharger soit le soir
vous la mettez au poignet vous le suivez
vous traquez votre sommeil soit vous
avez fait la nuit vous la recharger
pendant que vous vous préparez une
demi-heure tous les partis pour une
journée sans aucun problème donc ça
c'est aussi très très bien puisque je
vous parle de données de santé vous avez
différents capteurs au dos de votre
montre premier capteur ça va être un
nouveau capteur qui est là pour la spo2
c'est la saturation en oxygène de votre
sens par les tra savoir où est-ce que
vous en êtes au niveau de la saturation
donc bon c'est vraiment un indicateur il
faut pas l'utiliser comme une donnée
médical ça ne remplacera jamais une
consultation médical ou un suivi avec
des appareils vraiment vraiment vraiment
adapté par contre si vous voulez le
faire vous pouvez le faire c'est à dire
que regarde là j'avais une saturation à
97 des 42 minutes je fais une nouvelle
lecture doit rester immobile je ne dois
pas bougé et lâchés à 90% une ou dix
c'est une estimation et ensuite vous
allez dans vos apps et vous allez
pouvoir retrouver l'application
cardiogramme vous permettra à mesurer
alors moi je la vis à mesurer toutes les
trois minutes à intervalles réguliers on
n'est pas obligé de le mettre toutes les
trois minutes que je vis reproché ici
c'est que c'est en anglais donc si vous
ne parlez pas l'anglais alors on
comprend un soyez rassurés mais c'est
vrai que c'est un peu ballot ça aurait
été bien de l'avoir sur cette montre en
version complètement française on voit
quand on est monté un petit peu au cirad
et je suis monté à combien là j'ai tapé
à 100 à 3h30 de l'après midi c'est un
peu ballot ça c'est toute la partie
santé mais vous avez également gros
focus sur le sport est un des très gros
usage sur les montres connecter une
application qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils nous mettent en avant c'est
l'application bien-être alors
l'application bien-être al intéressant
parce qu'elle permet de savoir où est-ce
que vous en êtes par rapport à votre
activité votre sommeil fitness cardio je
suis pas un grand sportif alors oui je
fais pas beaucoup de sport ça se voit
tout de suite par contre j'ai tous mes
résultats qu'ils soient donc si vous
faites du sport et bien vous le verrez
tout va être mon histoire et vous verrez
réponse à une lecture un peu rapide en
fait de là où vous en êtes au niveau de
votre suivi de santé sport me redonne
mais mes informations sont l'oxygène
dans le sang sont mon rythme cardiaque
et si je vais aller faire du sport et
bien j'ai des tonnes d'applications et
je vous dis vous avez notamment
l'application de nike nike rhône club si
vous voulez aller courir vous avez ce
qu'il faut ici alors moi je ne cours pas
donc forcément je vais pas l'utiliser
mais si vous êtes sportif dites vous
bien qu'avec cette mante vous avez accès
à tout ce qu'il vous faudra puisque vous
avez tout l'écosystème webos de google
est bien évidemment le ps store et
toutes les applications qui sont
disponibles soit les stars mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là et oui forcément on va
avoir une onde qui vous servira pour le
suivi de santé pour le sport bien
évidemment pour le sommet tout ça je
vous ai expliqué mais également pour
tous qui va être notification pour des
appels vous pouvez passer des appels
téléphoniques directement ici depuis
votre montre mêmes répondent alors c'est
parce qu'elle est plus discret lorsqu'on
revient par alassane au come ca g ration
de fer k2000 wicked je suis là tu peux
arriver mais pour autant si vous avez
besoin vous pouvez le faire vous
décrocher rapidement en mode mains
libres sans aucun problème donc ça aussi
c'est très très bien et vous pouvez en
plus profiter de spotify et de youtube
musique offline bien évidemment vous
avez une application sur ios mais
également sur android que même si vous
avez un iphone vous pouvez venir
utiliser votre monde fossiles de sixième
génération très facilement et donc ça
c'est bien l'application c'est webos va
pouvoir venir changer votre cadre entrer
facilement vous allez avoir à votre
carte de notification votre agenda votre
assistante d'albret prévenir tout
paramétrer ici parce que il ya un moment
on se doute qu'on est limité vu la
taille de la montre pour venir tout
appel ne serait ce que pour venir taper
le code de votre wifi vous voulez le
faire directement ici depuis votre
application webos si on veut rentrer un
peu dans le technique on a ici il montre
avec un écran amoled 3,25 cm 416 par 416
pixels à 326 pixels par pouce on peut
activer cielo l'oiseau display ce qui
devait vous aurez toujours quelque chose
sur votre écran vous verrez toujours là
donc ça c'est assez intéressant qui dit
amoled dit oled forcément donc tous les
pixels noirs sont des pixels et un que
cela consomme pas énormément leurs
oiseaux displayed alors toujours un peu
plus que si vous ne mettez pas mais
c'est pas énorme ici vous êtes du
bluetooth 5.0 vous avez dû adresser pour
le paiement dématérialisé donc si vous
utilisez google paye et que votre carte
bleue est rentré pour venir payer avec
votre montre en idf s'est très
facilement donc ça aussi c'est vachement
bien vous avez également agpl elle est
étanche à 3 tm 3 tm égale 30 mètres donc
vous pouvez aller nager avec bien
évidemment avec le bracelet en silicone
bombe à vittek le bracelet en cuir et
c'est une honte qui coûte 299 euros dans
à configuration que vous est présentée
ici avec le bracelet en silicone il
existe différentes configurations
différentes finitions je vous ai mis le
lien en bas dans la description aller
jeter un coup d'oeil parce que c'est
vrai que c'est une montre intéressant
j'ai testé plusieurs mondes de fossiles
et à chaque fois les finitions sont
vraiment à la hauteur ce qui me plaît
ici c'est le fait d'avoir ces deux
boutons vous pouvez donc la
personnaliser comme vous le souhaitez
plutôt orientée sport plutôt orientés
santé orienté productivité vite tous les
jours très facilement donc ça c'est bien
le fait de voir passer ces coups de fil
c'est vraiment très très bien également
enfin bref elle a plein d'options qui
sont hyper sexy surtout cette plateforme
snapdragon 4100 plus qui lui apportera
une meilleure autonomie et plus de
performances si elle vous intéresse
évidemment tous les liens sont en bas
d'un description a vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez comment vous la
trouvez cette mode collectif aussi
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu deux mondes
connectés le fossile est ce que celle ci
pourrait vous tentez vous marquez tout
ça en bas à vos claviers juste en bail
si vous avez des questions vous pouvez y
aller sur ce je vous embrasse nous
embrasse fort demandez-vous très
rapidement pour continuer à parler tech
bd évidemment parce qu'il ya plein de
choses à raconter et ça c'est vachement
bien
[Musique]